[Musica]
quando ero piccola sognavo di volare un
pomeriggio ero in un grande prato verde
con mio papà quando ecco sopra di noi un
elicottero bellissimo che volava basso
basso mio padre era di mentalità aperta
forse anche troppo indica il cielo e mi
disse quello è l'elicottero del soccorso
alpino
le donne adesso non possono farne parte
ma quando sarai grande chissà magari sì
lui mi ha sempre insegnato a sognare e
che insegna a sognare fa molto di più di
chi regala un sogno così crescendo ho
seguito le mie passioni sono diventata
atleta di snowboard ho vinto tante gare
qualcuno a livello europeo anche sono
stati degli anni bellissimi il bello che
se ci sentivamo forti ma se noi
prendiamo un video di snowboard attuale
vediamo che supera addirittura i
videogames di quegli anni
[Musica]
è incredibile no come l'essere umano
tende a spostare i propri limiti sempre
di più e sempre più in fretta più facevo
l'atleta è più capivo quanto conti
maggiormente la nostra forza mentale
rispetto a quella fisica e di come la
nostra mente possa non solo farci star
male o bene ma anche farci ovviamente
vincere o perdere e lì è nata la mia
passione per la scienza della mente la
psicologia
attualmente la mia professione e quella
di psicologa e mi occupo anche di
ricerca scientifica prevalentemente
sulle persone che praticano sport
estremi come l'arrampicata oil free ride
cioè lo sci o lo snowboard fuoripista
vi siete mai chiesti perché a qualcuno
piace salire una montagna su fino alla
cima
finché guardando in giù non vede neanche
di due finisce vede solo centinaia e
centinaia di metri di di rupo e sta bene
così c'è giusto sbagliato nello
scegliere uno sport o conta di più
seguire se stessi la propria strada ma
che ci piacciono non è possibile predire
a musicista di suonare a un artista di
creare a un cantante di cantare così
come non è possibile proibire a un
alpinista amante della montagna di
scalarla accarezzarla e viverla gli
sport estremi sono sempre di più sempre
più diffusi sempre più praticati anche
da donne bambini e possiamo dire anche
sempre più sicuri infatti ad esempio
ormai da anni per chi pratica il
freeride esiste lo zaino con l'air bag
che può permettergli di salvarsi in caso
di distacco del manto nevoso
forse potreste pensare che chi pratica
uno sport estremo sia agitato turbato
super attivato invece anni di ricerca
scientifica ci mostrano che è il
contrario
ho misurato il livello di stress a un
centinaio di persone che praticano sport
estremi lo stress e tensione attivazione
del corpo della mente
possiamo pensare che il massimo di
stress sia un attacco di panico e il
dimostra il sonno ciò che emerso è molto
interessante chi fa sport estremi a
livello di stress davvero basso
così basso che possiamo dire che sì
espressi al contrario cioè facendo poco
o niente perché si annoia facilmente
infatti ha bisogno di molti più stimoli
rispetto alla media per sentirsi vivo e
tende a funzionare meglio in situazioni
complesse di pericolo o di emergenza
non a caso la scienza ha chiamato questa
categoria di persone sensation seekers
cioè ricercatori di sensazioni dopo aver
visto tutti questi dati se sensation
seekers ho pensato se ci sono persone
che si stressano al contrario di altre
neanche la più conosciuta tecnica di
rilassamento potrebbe andare bene per
tutti così ho pensato di the arn una
dedicata a questa categoria di persone
una tecnica di rilassamento dinamica per
il potenziamento del benessere
ho messo assieme degli elementi quindi
che potenziano il benessere ormai
risaputo che la natura ci fa stare bene
migliora il nostro livello di umore così
come ambiente per praticare questa
tecnica ho cercato un posto nella natura
un posto silenzioso tranquillo con
l'aria fresca senza fonti di distrazione
e ovviamente mi è venuta subito in mente
la neve fresca
così ho chiamato questa tecnica mind
full freeride che unisce i benefici
della meditazione a quelli del freeride
con la prima parte di meditazione si
impara rallentare fino ad immergersi nel
presente nel qui e ora che è l'unico
tempo che noi abbiamo la parte di
meditazione su bach si basa su esercizi
di visualizzazione e di respirazione
noi crediamo di respirare bene invece
media già dalle otto anni di età
smettiamo di respirare correttamente con
il respiro possiamo ad esempio
migliorare la nostra concentrazione
rallentare i battiti cardiaci e
migliorare la qualità del sonno
dopo questa parte di meditazione c'è la
parte di freeride è un po difficile
descrivere che cosa significhi fare
freeride a chi non l'ha mai provato è
qualcosa di veramente incredibile perché
è come stare in un altra
tensione in cui tutto è bianco e
luminoso il terreno e soffice infatti si
può cadere senza farsi male è come
andare sulle nuvole
[Musica]
l'amalfi freeride prevede quindi
l'esercizio fisico non solo perché
questa tecnica è dedicata a chi fatica a
stare fermo a lungo ma soprattutto
perché con l'attività fisica avviene il
rilascio dei cosiddetti ormoni del
benessere quindi permette di stare
meglio
inoltre si pratica in gruppo e questo fa
sì che vengano condivise delle emozioni
ricche delle esperienze veramente
intense questo permette di rafforzare il
senso di appartenenza che ha un bisogno
molto importante che tutti noi abbiamo
inoltre mentre si pratica freeride e nel
nostro cervello accade qualcosa di
incredibile
si attiva l'area del piacere il
cosiddetto circuito della ricompensa che
si attiva quando noi proviamo qualcosa
di veramente veramente intensa la
sensazione più forte che si possa
provare
infatti se ti va anche nell'amore
pensate che la voglia di attivare questo
circuito della ricompensa è talmente
elevata da superare addirittura i
bisogni primari come la fame e la sete è
stato visto su uno studio condotto su
dei topolini che se li viene offerta la
possibilità di mangiare o di schiacciare
una leva per somministrarsi una
stimolazione diretta in quest'area
cerebrale del piacere i topolini
continuano a schiacciare la leva
dimenticandosi di mangiare e arrivando
addirittura quasi a morire di fame
ecco perché a molti piacciono gli sport
estremi
la mind fulcri ride si pratica in
condizioni di massima sicurezza
a volte però può capitare che in natura
ci siano dei pericoli oggettivi come il
terreno instabile o il maltempo e può
capitare senza volerlo di oltrepassare
il limite il concetto di limite qualcosa
di difficile da definire
tante volte può essere quel centimetro o
quel secondo che separa la vita dalla
morte
in ogni caso su tutti i terreni in
queste condizioni di emergenza
interviene il soccorso alpino
quando ero piccola sognavo davvero di
volare in quell'elicottero e mai avrei
creduto quel sogno così grande e si
potesse avverare
[Musica]
ora sono davvero felice di far parte di
questa grande famiglia che è soccorso
alpino e di poter permettere a qualcuno
che si ritrova in condizioni di pericolo
di continuare a sognare
[Applauso]